so next game
and I have black again hurrah
Lithuania
here you learn flags,
well
he only knows Slavic and thinks that's
an innovation or something,
okay,
I've already lost with the nice variant
but there was nothing there
so two and four are straight away
so now here five I know at least
a little bit about
the C5 err is now knight A6 or
dc4 I want the C4
which is unusual in the position
good you can of course
do CD4 very simply play
and say that the queen
is then bad on Z2
you probably can
Now you could play it quite simply.
Bishop the four idea ed5 then knight
C6 gain speed and say the pawn D4
is somehow unfavorable to cover
The four or F6
actually likes F6 better
so he will probably play bishop F3
and then attack me too
so
yes
knight A5 an idea jumps A5 C4
jump on the knight D5 bishop the
five queens monkey 3 is okay let's
try something like that
provoke here,
yes, I thought that might be a
weakening, but of course it could also
be nonsense, perhaps so that G5
comes around the knight has its roots.
Probably
nothing else can come to mind, but
if now on G5 takes hg
then I might also have
the move G4  G5 G4
so that he moves the bishop away from F3
yes, of course, the simple way
to answer that and by no means a
bad one yes
I think he did
his job
yes maybe wants to move H4
okay
think of knight F5
I would think so at the moment
Pawns win
or jump 5 would win one so
that six
so again be careful because of
the uprooted knight
and the bishop is a bit vulnerable on
F3 so knight F5 knight D4 is
now a drugs probably
not so clear how to defend it now
what is he doing?  now here
yes you can do that
knight F5 and then rook F3 yes or Tom
the three
F3 but also looks a bit uncomfortable
yes okay
if he moves it anyway to F3 so G6
yes
okay I'll try on the finish line
maybe double
the move B3  It
was a bit stupid,
of course, it's still stock
songs like that but
it's not that easy at all
Knight A4 C5 okay
he wants Knight F14 that's
probably a really good idea
in principle at least
but I can also
play Rook C2
Tom C2
Isn't that good
Queen B4 or something like that,
okay, come on, I have to
think of a little activity here, my
cell phone like Springer E6 haha ​​yes, but
Springer F5 is now
really or
the four are hanging so
the three are of course also but
Springer H5 or maybe
So
jumper simply D45
F3 is coming
a little faster here
I only have a minute left, luckily he's
not fast either
so what are we going to do now
time warning
F3 is not online at the position but
now
wow
he's still really pissing himself
off  up or yes
okay but of course still
attack it I'm so lame Rook E8 bishop has three too isn't exactly
bad
yes bishop E4 shame
shame
I'm such a llama crutch remember was
totally fat the position
he didn't see but it didn't matter
[ __ ]
Well I'm checkmate with Tom the seven
unfortunately man how unnecessary
Check
yes so I know
on time
we have six tower the four
tower C1 so B1
and the lights go out shame
but all the other moves are
probably probably not
okay either